When you think back to your childhood, do you remember long afternoons of doing not much? Maybe building things with Legos or devoting hours to putting on a play with your dolls? Playtime might seem like it's just for fun and less important than the real work of learning, reading, writing, and arithmetic. But psychologists who study children's learning have found that in reality, children learn best through play. And as the amount of time that kids get to play has shrunk in recent decades. some researchers are hoping to bring playful learning back to children's lives. So why is play so important? What do we learn through play that we can't learn in other ways?
回想童年时，你是否还记得那些无所事事的漫长午后？也许是搭积木，又或是花上几个小时和玩偶玩过家家？游戏时间看起来似乎只是为了娱乐，不如学习、阅读、写作和算术这些“正事”重要。但研究儿童学习的心理学家发现，事实上，孩子在游戏中学习的效果最好。随着近几十年来孩子们游戏时间的缩减，一些研究人员希望能将“游戏化学习”重新带回孩子们的生活中。那么，为什么游戏如此重要？我们在游戏中能学到哪些通过其他方式无法学到的东西呢？
What's the difference between free play and play that's guided by a parent, teacher, or other adult? What does playful learning look like in a classroom? What does it look like at home and in the larger world? How is technology changing children's play? And what can parents do to encourage more play and play learning for their kids. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life.
自由游戏与由家长、老师或其他成年人引导的游戏之间有什么区别？课堂上的游戏化学习是什么样的？在家里和更广阔的世界里又是什么样的？科技正在如何改变儿童的游戏方式？家长们又能做些什么来鼓励孩子进行更多的游戏和游戏化学习？欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》，本节目旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。
I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Kathy Hirsch-Pasik, a professor of psychology at Temple University and a senior fellow at the Brookings Institution. Dr. Hirsch-Pasik has spent decades studying how children learn through play play, and then bringing that knowledge to parents, educators, and others. She is author of hundreds of scientific articles and 17 books, including the New York Times bestseller, becoming brilliant what science tells us about raising successful children, which, by the way, APA published, and her latest, making schools work, bringing the science of learning
我是主持人 Kim Mills。今天的嘉宾是天普大学心理学教授、布鲁金斯学会高级研究员 Kathy Hirsch-Pasik 博士。Hirsch-Pasik 博士几十年来一直致力于研究儿童如何通过游戏进行学习，并将这些知识传授给家长、教育工作者和其他人。她撰写了数百篇科学论文和 17 本书，包括《纽约时报》畅销书《变得卓越：科学告诉我们如何培养成功的孩子》（顺便提一下，这本书是由美国心理学会出版的），以及她最新的著作《让学校发挥作用：将学习科学转化为快乐的课堂实践》。
to joyful classroom practice. Dr. Hirsch Passick is an APA fellow and has received numerous awards for her work. She and her team also recently received a $19 million grant from the Lego Foundation in support of their work on playful learning. Dr. Hirsch-Pasick, thank you for joining me today. It is such a pleasure to be here. Kim, you ready to play? You bet. Let's do it. You've done years of research that has found the kids learn best through play. Why is that? What do they learn through play that they don't learn in other ways? Well, let's try to try to Just imagine what you do when you're playing. Now, as a scientist, I play all the time.
Hirsch-Pasik 博士是美国心理学会会士，因其杰出贡献获得了无数奖项。她和她的团队最近还获得了乐高基金会 1900 万美元的资助，以支持他们在游戏化学习方面的研究。Hirsch-Pasik 博士，感谢您今天参加我们的节目。很高兴能来到这里。Kim，你准备好玩了吗？当然，开始吧。您多年来的研究发现，孩子在游戏中学习效果最好。这是为什么呢？他们在游戏中能学到什么其他方式学不到的东西？嗯，让我们试着想象一下你在玩耍时在做什么。作为一名科学家，我一直在“玩”。
I'm pretty curious. I want to know what makes things work. And so I explore. And as I'm exploring things, I'm discovering new things. I'm learning, hmm, how do children think? How do children talk? How do children play? And when I do that, I start to get answers to questions that I might not have even thought
我很好奇。我想知道事物运作的原理，所以我去探索。在探索的过程中，我发现了新事物。我在学习：嗯，孩子们是怎么思考的？他们是怎么说话的？他们是怎么玩的？当我这样做时，我开始找到一些问题的答案，如果我不是一个发现者，不是在现实世界中进行探索，我可能根本就不会想到这些问题。
about had I not just been a discoverer, and explore in the real world. And I'd like to argue that it's not just kids play. I think even adults need more play in their life right now. We are so busy all the time that when you say, how are you? It's an okay answer to say, oh, I'm busy. And now I say, I'm so sorry, are you getting any time to explore the world? So what does playful learning look like in a classroom and how can teachers incorporate play into their classes, especially when they feel that they have limited time to teach so much content? Well, you know, you can teach content in a playful way. And that's what we mean by guided play. You can have a learning goal, but you can set up an environment so that the children
我想说，这不仅仅是孩子们的游戏。我认为即使是成年人现在也需要在生活中增加更多的游戏。我们总是太忙了，以至于当你问“你好吗？”时，回答“哦，我很忙”似乎是可以接受的。现在我会说：“真遗憾，你还有时间去探索这个世界吗？”那么，课堂上的游戏化学习是什么样的？老师们如何将游戏融入课堂，特别是在他们觉得教学内容太多、时间有限的情况下？嗯，你知道，你可以用游戏化的方式教授内容。这就是我们所说的“引导式游戏”。你可以设定一个学习目标，但你可以营造一个环境，让孩子们
do that exploration and discovery. They are the agents of their own learning. So what do we mean by that. We mean that we learn better when you're active, not passive. So think of what school is like often, sitting in chairs and rows. It's not the way human brains learn, so say it, the science. We learn better when we're engaged in what we're doing, not when we're distracted. We learn best when something is meaningful, not when it has no meaning at all to us. When it's socially interactive. We learned that during COVID when it's iterative. We learn a little bit more each time. We're kind of like in jazz when we learn things in different ways. And finally, here's the shocker. We learn things better when it's joyful and not when it's bored. That, I'll just finish the
去进行探索和发现。他们是自己学习的主体。我们所说的“主体”是什么意思呢？意思是当我们主动而非被动时，学习效果更好。想想学校通常是什么样子：坐在成排的椅子上。这不是人类大脑学习的方式，科学就是这么说的。当我们全身心投入所做的事情时，而不是分心时，我们学得更好。当学习内容有意义，而不是对我们毫无意义时，我们学得最好。当它是社会互动时——我们在新冠疫情期间学到了这一点——当它是迭代的，即我们每次多学一点时，学习效果更好。我们就像在演奏爵士乐，以不同的方式学习事物。最后，最令人惊讶的一点是：当学习过程充满乐趣而不是枯燥乏味时，我们学得更好。这就是我们所说的
thought here, is that that is what we mean by active, playful learning. It has a learning goal, But the pedagogy requires that teachers have more fun teaching again, and therefore the kids will have more fun learning again. So I find it easy to picture this when we're talking about elementary school children, but what happens when we get into middle school or a high school? We don't have little kids running around playing with interactive toys to learn. What do you do with the older kids? Well, you actually don't need the interactive toys. As I said, even scientists really are doing guided play all the time. So I'm going to give you an example from my college classes.
“主动的游戏化学习”。它有学习目标，但这种教学法要求老师们重新享受教学的乐趣，因此孩子们也会重新享受学习的乐趣。我觉得在谈论小学生时很容易想象这一点，但到了初中或高中会怎样呢？我们没有小孩子跑来跑去玩互动玩具来学习。对于大一点的孩子，你们怎么做呢？嗯，其实你不需要互动玩具。正如我所说，即使是科学家也一直在进行“引导式游戏”。所以我举一个我大学课堂的例子。
In our college classrooms, we use a guided play approach. And I ask students to learn psychology, but to also, while they're learning psychology, learn what I call the Six Seas. And all this was developed with my collaborator, Dr. Roberta Galingoff, from the University of Delaware. So number one is how to get along with other people. Then built on that, which is collaboration, you get communication skills. Do you write well?
在我们的大学课堂上，我们采用引导式游戏的方法。我要求学生学习心理学，但同时，在学习心理学的过程中，还要学习我所说的“六个C”。所有这些都是我和我的合作者、特拉华大学的 Roberta Galingoff 博士共同开发的。第一点是如何与他人相处。在此基础上，即协作，你还要获得沟通技巧。你写得好吗？
Are you able to give good oral communication that's convincing? Built on that is your content. You have to learn the content. It's really important in high school and college, whatever. Built on that is critical thinking. We're not so good at that, whether it's in high school or whether it is in college class. And in fact, AI is teaching that to us right now. We have to know how to critically think our way out of things that are misinformation or real
你是否能够进行令人信服的口头交流？在此基础上是内容。你必须学习内容。这在高中和大学等阶段非常重要。在此基础上是批判性思维。无论是在高中还是大学课堂，我们在这方面做得都不太好。事实上，人工智能现在正在教我们这一点。我们必须知道如何通过批判性思维来辨别什么是错误信息，什么是真实
information. And how about creative innovation? In that world of AI, it's going to be even more important to have the original thought than to be able to just have a thought. And finally, we have to have the confidence to take intellectual risks. all of those things come out of a more guided play or active playful learning approach. So in our classrooms, what I do is I only lecture once a week. And what happens on the other day that we meet?
信息。还有创造性创新呢？在人工智能的世界里，拥有原创思想比仅仅拥有一个想法更为重要。最后，我们必须有承担智力风险的信心。所有这些都源于一种更具引导性的游戏或主动的游戏化学习方法。所以在我们的课堂上，我每周只讲一次课。那我们见面的另一天会发生什么呢？
My undergrads and I have a discussion about a theme. And who gets to choose the theme? My students. Because I can teach psychology, whether it's this term's theme, your brain on art, written by Susan Mag Sammon, which became our textbook, or whether we're teaching about prejudice, which I think a lot of people ought to learn about today, because prejudice and hate and stereotyping are everywhere we can touch, I think, in the world today, or whether we're learning about the computerized you. And so my students engage in the study of these topics
我和我的本科生们会讨论一个主题。谁来选择主题？我的学生。因为我可以教授心理学，无论是这学期的主题——Susan Mag Sammon 撰写的《你的大脑与艺术》（这成了我们的教科书），还是我们讨论偏见（我认为今天很多人都应该了解这一点，因为偏见、仇恨和刻板印象在当今世界随处可见），又或是我们学习“计算机化的你”。所以我的学生们会参与到这些他们关心的话题的研究中，
that they care about, and we move toward the learning goal of understanding psychology methodology, but we do it in the context of a theme that they care about. And believe me that two years later, they could take my midterm or my final, and they could ace it. And I challenge any other professor to be able to say that. Throwing down the concept. I am. I am. What about unstructured play, the kind of free play that's not guided by teachers or any adults? What are kids learned from that? Oh, they learn so much. You know, if we want our children to be worker bees as they grow up, then we fill every single moment with what they are supposed to do
我们朝着理解心理学方法论的学习目标前进，但我们是在他们关心的话题背景下进行的。相信我，两年后，他们参加我的期中或期末考试，都能拿到高分。我挑战任何其他教授，看他们能否这么说。我正在下战书。确实如此。那非结构化游戏呢？那种不由老师或任何成年人引导的自由游戏。孩子们能从中学会什么？哦，他们学到的太多了。你知道，如果我们希望我们的孩子长大后成为“工蜂”，那么我们就把他们的每一刻都填满他们“应该”做的事情，
and how they're supposed to do it. And that's really good because they will learn how to follow everything that they're told. On the other hand, what we might want are people who are managers and bosses in the future. Now, you don't want every kid to grow up as a boss, certainly not in your living room, certainly not around dinner. but you do want them to know the skills of working with other kids, of organizing things, and of figuring out for themselves that the world around us is really pretty interesting and we don't notice most of it.
以及他们“应该”如何去做。这确实很好，因为他们会学会如何服从所有的指令。另一方面，我们可能希望未来出现的是管理者和老板。当然，你不会希望每个孩子长大后都当老板，在客厅里或晚餐时肯定不希望这样。但你确实希望他们掌握与同龄人合作、组织事物以及自己发现周围世界其实非常有趣、而我们大多数时候都忽略了这些的技能。
And I'm amazed when I watch my kids who haven't had a lot of screen time, my grandkids, and who are playing with their stuffies, that they actually are kind of. coming up with narrative. They're writing stories. They're solving dilemmas. They're learning how to solve world problems. Like I told them the other day about the oil spill. And I said, oh, what are we going to do with this oil spill that just happened in the Gulf?
当我看着我的孩子们——那些没有太多屏幕时间的孩子，我的孙辈们——玩他们的毛绒玩具时，我感到很惊讶，他们实际上是在编造叙事。他们在写故事，在解决困境。他们在学习如何解决世界性问题。比如前几天我告诉他们关于石油泄漏的事情。我说：“哦，对于刚刚在海湾发生的这次石油泄漏，我们该怎么办？”
And they came up with creative solutions. Now they might not be what the engineers would say. But that's okay. In free play, they're mastering all of these skills, including skills. that are so important, and we've been learning more and more about the importance of social skills and social navigation from a social human brain and how that helps us with content. Well, you need to have those relationships. And when our kids are stuck on a playground and they have to figure out how to get Johnny off the swing when they want it,
他们想出了创造性的解决方案。虽然这些方案可能不是工程师会给出的，但这没关系。在自由游戏中，他们掌握了所有这些技能，包括我们越来越认识到其重要性的社交技能和社交导航能力。从社会化的人类大脑来看，这些技能如何帮助我们处理内容？嗯，你需要建立那些关系。当我们的孩子在操场上，他们必须想办法在想要秋千时如何让 Johnny 从上面下来，
that is a social navigation. People have been talking for years about how kids' playtime has plummeted, both the time that they get to play in school and free play outside of school. When we were preparing for this interview, we found an article in APA's magazine, The Monitor, that quoted you on this topic back in 2009. I know. It's been going on a long time. But have you seen any improvements since then, or is the trend toward kids getting less playtime in the way? their lives continuing? Well, I think we have to look at what's happened in society. You know, in 2009, we were screaming about what David Alkind wrote about called the hurried
那就是一种社交导航。多年来，人们一直在谈论孩子们的游戏时间如何急剧下降，包括他们在学校的游戏时间和校外的自由游戏时间。在准备这次采访时，我们在美国心理学会的杂志《观察家》上发现了一篇 2009 年引用您关于这个话题的文章。我知道。这种情况已经持续很长时间了。但从那时起，您看到有什么改善吗？还是说孩子们游戏时间减少的趋势在继续？嗯，我认为我们必须看看社会发生了什么。你知道，在 2009 年，我们还在大声疾呼 David Alkind 所说的“匆忙的
child. I would add to that that we really should be talking about the hurried parent. We have just cobbled our life together so closely, so tightly that we're running kind of on a machine and we think we need to be CEO parents. The result of that, when David first wrote about it, way back in, I think it was the 80s, you know, or maybe the early 90s, was that kids were having activity after activity after activity with no time to even process the activities that they were in. I would say that's happened even more today because there are even more activities to engage in. Add to that, that something dramatic happened in 2007, and that was the invention of the iPhone. Right.
孩子”。我要补充一点，我们真的应该谈谈“匆忙的家长”。我们把生活安排得太紧凑、太严密了，以至于我们像机器一样运转，我们认为我们需要成为“CEO 型家长”。当 David 最初在 80 年代或 90 年代初写到这一点时，结果就是孩子们参加了一个又一个活动，甚至没有时间去消化他们所参与的活动。我想说，今天这种情况甚至更严重了，因为有更多的活动可以参加。再加上 2007 年发生了一件戏剧性的事情，那就是 iPhone 的发明。没错。
And in 2011, came the invention that piggybacked on that that we call the iPad. And with that came a lot of people who realized that this was their moment. They could create educational material in the form of. of apps and we would have digital, as Disney once called it, edutainment. Now, some of the stuff is good, but I have to say that a whole lot of it is not. And in a paper that Merritt Merritt Meyer wrote out of Jenny Rudetsky's lab and we worked with them on it, we asked, what does make a good educational app and do the 100 most downloaded apps actually have any educational value.
2011 年，又出现了基于此的发明，我们称之为 iPad。随之而来的是许多人意识到这是他们的时刻。他们可以制作以应用程序形式呈现的教育材料，也就是迪士尼曾经所说的“寓教于乐”。现在，其中一些东西是不错的，但我不得不说，很大一部分并不是。在 Merritt Meyer 从 Jenny Rudetsky 实验室撰写的一篇论文中，我们与他们合作进行了研究，我们问：什么才算好的教育类应用程序？下载量最大的 100 个应用程序真的有教育价值吗？
Now I grant it, this is two years old, so maybe everything's changed, but I doubt it. And at that time, only two of the apps actually made it to what we would call in the science. Educational. That's astounding. Now you say, but, okay, a lot of kids aren't spending time on apps, are they? Well, by middle school, they're spending 14 hours a day on this stuff. Now, think about that. That's over a 70-hour work week that they're spending in front of a screen.
现在我承认，这是两年前的数据了，所以也许一切都变了，但我对此表示怀疑。当时，只有两个应用程序真正达到了我们科学界所说的“教育性”。这太令人震惊了。现在你会说，好吧，很多孩子并没有花时间在应用程序上，对吧？嗯，到了初中，他们每天花 14 个小时在这些东西上。现在想想看，这相当于每周工作 70 多个小时，他们都坐在屏幕前。
Sitting, by the way, often docilely, and maybe sometimes convinced, and APA's written a lot about this, that they're really engaged in social media. Now, the first two things to note about that is that it ain't social if you're not with another person, even though it can mimic it. And the second is, it's a lot of downtime spent on social. screen that isn't being spent out looking at trees, watching ants, running around. So we have to be as parents, I think, more conscious of the balance here. And by the way, we've written about this too, of also balancing what we do as parents. Because we're addicted to these screens as well.
顺便说一下，通常是温顺地坐着，有时甚至被说服——美国心理学会对此写了很多文章——认为他们真的在参与社交媒体。首先要注意的两点是：如果你不和另一个人在一起，那就不叫社交，尽管它可以模仿社交。第二点是，在屏幕上花费了大量的时间，而这些时间本可以用来观察树木、观察蚂蚁、四处奔跑。所以作为家长，我认为我们必须更加关注这里的平衡。顺便说一下，我们也写过关于这个的文章，也要平衡我们作为家长所做的事情。因为我们也对这些屏幕上瘾了。
and when we are and our kids see us in front of the screen all the time and not looking in their eyes, their message to the child is, I'm not as important as the screen is. And in fact, I want you to know that for this program, I pulled my grandchildren over Thanksgiving. And I said, well, does it disturb you when adults are on phones a lot? This is a six and eight year old, and they said, yeah. and I said, why? I said, well, we don't get any attention. They're just sitting looking at their phone
当我们上瘾，而孩子们看到我们一直盯着屏幕，而不是看着他们的眼睛时，他们从孩子那里得到的信息就是：我没有屏幕重要。事实上，我想让你知道，为了这个节目，我在感恩节期间询问了我的孙辈们。我说：“当大人们经常看手机时，你们会感到困扰吗？”这是两个 6 岁和 8 岁的孩子，他们说：“会。”我说：“为什么？”他们说：“嗯，我们得不到任何关注。他们只是坐在那里看手机，
and every so often they look up at us. And I said, well, what do you think we should do about those adults? And my six-year-old said, we need to do something. We need to tell them that they are just two-legged screenwatchers and that we need them to look at us. So my point in all of this, Has it gotten worse? I believe it has. There's less recess. There's less time for children to just have downtime, which is when we browse things and learn about the world. And those skills are so very, very important for a social brain. So very important.
偶尔抬头看我们一眼。”我说：“那你们觉得我们应该怎么对待那些大人？”我 6 岁的孙子说：“我们需要做点什么。我们需要告诉他们，他们只是‘两条腿的屏幕观察者’，我们需要他们看着我们。”所以，我所有这些观点的核心是：情况变糟了吗？我相信是的。课间休息少了。孩子们没有时间去拥有单纯的“停机时间”，而那正是我们浏览事物并了解世界的时候。这些技能对于社会化的大脑来说非常、非常重要。非常重要。
A few moments ago, you mentioned research looking at the 100 most popular apps and only two met the test. were actually being useful educationally. Not to be a commercial for anybody, but can you give me an idea of what those apps were, what they did, what made them as good as they are? Yeah, so as I said you before, I look at a series of criteria when I look at media, and I've worked with a lot of media companies now
刚才您提到了对 100 个最受欢迎的应用程序的研究，只有两个通过了测试，真正具有教育意义。不是为了给谁做广告，但您能给我举个例子，说明那些是什么应用程序，它们做了什么，是什么让它们如此出色吗？是的，正如我之前对你说的，我在看媒体时会参考一系列标准，我现在已经与许多媒体公司合作，
as we try to flesh this out. Where does the science meet digital media? And it's a very important question that I think we have to ask. So where is the consensus in the scientific literature? As I mentioned before, there's consensus around we learn best when you're active, kind of mind's on, not just swiping, but minds on. When you're engaged, not distracted, that's where the media industry really has a problem. They think that by putting more bells and whistles on things,
试图充实这一点。科学在哪里与数字媒体相遇？这是一个我认为我们必须提出的非常重要的问题。那么科学文献中的共识在哪里？正如我之前提到的，共识在于：当我们主动时，即“心智在线”而不仅仅是滑动屏幕时，我们学得最好。当我们全身心投入而不是分心时——这正是媒体行业真正存在问题的地方。他们认为通过在事物上增加更多的花哨功能，
the kids will be more entertained. And while it's kind of like digital candy, it isn't good for learning. When it's meaningful, that can be a whole lot of things, but it should be something that's culturally diverse as well so that people can find me in the characters that they're looking at. It's when it's socially interactive where two people can play,
孩子们会更开心。虽然这有点像“数字糖果”，但它对学习并不好。当它有意义时，它可以包含很多东西，但也应该在文化上具有多样性，这样人们才能在他们所看到的角色中找到自己。当它是社会互动时，即两个人可以一起玩，
not just being solo. That's not to say you should never do solo. We all play games like solitaire. But I would say that anytime you can play it with someone else, it's a really good thing, where it's iterative, where it keeps like in jazz taking the same theme and playing on it in different ways, not just doing the same thing every time. And finally, when it's enjoyable, when it can elicit joy. If you take those and you have a learning goal in mind, you can craft an app that is actually going to be educational or a, a metaverse activity that's going to be educational or an AI experience that's going to be educational. Short of those, what you're doing is you're providing more edutainment that kids watch passively,
而不是独自一人。这并不是说你不应该独自玩。我们都玩像纸牌这样的游戏。但我会说，任何时候如果你能和别人一起玩，那都是一件非常好的事情。当它是迭代的，就像爵士乐一样，不断采用同一个主题并以不同的方式演奏，而不是每次都做同样的事情。最后，当它令人愉快时，当它能激发快乐时。如果你采用这些标准，并且心中有学习目标，你就可以制作一个真正具有教育意义的应用程序，或者一个具有教育意义的元宇宙活动，或者一个具有教育意义的人工智能体验。除此之外，你所提供的只是更多的“寓教于乐”，孩子们被动地观看，
but where they're not as fully engaged, and they just don't learn as much from that. So I won't be an infomercial for the apps that passed, but I will tell you the criteria that kind of make it or break it. Well, let's talk about adults and play, because you did. mentioned a few moments ago that, you know, adults need to play as well. What do we learn as adults through playing? What does adult play look like as compared to learning play for youngsters? Well, I do think scientists play all the time. We're a curious bunch. We ask a lot of questions and we almost always ask questions we don't know the answers to. And that's an important thing, by the way, for parents to consider. When you want to ask
但他们并没有完全投入，他们从中也学不到那么多东西。所以我不会为那些通过测试的应用程序做广告，但我会告诉你那些决定成败的标准。好吧，让我们谈谈成年人和游戏，因为您刚才提到成年人也需要玩。作为成年人，我们通过玩耍学到了什么？与年轻人的学习性游戏相比，成人的游戏是什么样的？嗯，我确实认为科学家一直在玩。我们是一群好奇的人。我们问很多问题，而且我们几乎总是问我们不知道答案的问题。顺便说一下，这对家长来说是一个重要的考虑因素。当你想要提问时，
questions. Like ask cool questions. Like, I wonder how many straws it would take to support this glass of water. You know? Like, you have to think about the kinds of building block things that you build that can support something, how easy it is to topple something down. All that's physics. And as scientists, we ask these questions all the time, but adults usually ask kind of simple questions. Like what color is your shirt? What color is the doll's dress? Those are called closed questions in our world. And we want open-ended questions where kids have to really think and give you paragraphs as answers, not just one-word answers. So adults for scientists do that all the time. They ask the next question. They get the next discovery. We can do that too. And our world is so
问一些很酷的问题。比如，“我想知道需要多少根吸管才能支撑这杯水。”你知道吗？你必须思考你搭建的那些积木结构如何支撑某样东西，以及让某样东西倒塌是多么容易。所有这些都是物理学。作为科学家，我们一直在问这些问题，但成年人通常问一些简单的问题。比如“你的衬衫是什么颜色的？”“玩偶的裙子是什么颜色的？”在我们的世界里，这些被称为“封闭式问题”。我们想要的是“开放式问题”，让孩子们必须真正思考并给你段落作为答案，而不是仅仅一个词的回答。所以科学家们一直在这样做。他们问下一个问题。他们获得下一个发现。我们也可以这样做。我们的世界是如此
much more fun when we do it, when we change the rules of the game. We were playing adult games over the holidays. Families often do these. And what are those games? And are there games you can invent that are really fun? So we even had a new game that my son introduced called Consider the Source, where you had to rank things, anything, okay, like car brands, movies on a one to scale and the other people had to guess the number. That was a cool, invented game. And everyone had a blast doing it. So I'm going to put another gauntlet down on your show today. I would like us to all have a little bit more adult recess time. I think we need to invent the concept of adult recess and ask, what would you do if you tuck an hour and a half out of your day? I don't care if you
当我们这样做时，当我们改变游戏规则时，它会变得更有趣。假期里我们经常玩成人游戏。家庭通常会这样做。那些是什么游戏？有没有你可以发明的真正有趣的游戏？所以我们甚至有一个我儿子介绍的新游戏，叫“考虑来源”，你需要对事物进行排名，任何事物，比如汽车品牌、电影，按 1 到 10 的等级，其他人必须猜这个数字。那是一个很酷的自创游戏。每个人都玩得很开心。所以今天我要在你的节目中再次下战书。我希望我们所有人都能多一点“成人课间休息时间”。我认为我们需要发明“成人课间休息”的概念，并问问自己：如果你从一天中抽出一个半小时，你会做什么？我不在乎你
go to the park. I don't care if you watch the ants and wonder, why are they walking in a straight line? I think if we could see the world a little bit more like our children do, we'd be much more creative people, much more sane people, and parents come along. Give yourself that opportunity, and if you really want to have fun, follow the child's lead and learn how to play again. Now, you're working on a project that aims to bring playful learning into public spaces like bus stops, libraries, laundromats. So let's talk about that. What do those playful learning spaces look like and what do they accomplish? Yes, well, I invite all of you to come and look at playful learning landscapes.com. So believe it or not, one day, I thought, why aren't we showing off
去公园。我不在乎你是否观察蚂蚁并想知道：为什么它们排成一条直线行走？我认为如果我们能像孩子们那样多一点看待这个世界，我们会成为更有创造力的人，更理智的人，家长们也一样。给自己那个机会，如果你真的想玩得开心，跟随孩子的脚步，学习如何再次玩耍。现在，您正在进行一个旨在将游戏化学习带入公共空间的项目，比如公交车站、图书馆、自助洗衣店。那么，让我们谈谈这个。那些游戏化学习空间是什么样的？它们实现了什么？是的，我邀请你们所有人去看看 PlayfulLearningLandscapes.com。信不信由你，有一天我想：为什么我们不向现实世界中的人们展示
how this play works to people in the real world? The science gets here. hidden in journals, except when you're on a podcast. And then all of a sudden, it has life. And we brought that to life and started this project in 2010 in Central Park. And it was called the ultimate block party. And we had 28 science-inspired activities around the park. And kids and parents came. And we were told that we'd be super lucky if we got 6,000 people to come to Central Park that day and participate in all of our activities. Over 50,000 people came. They had a blast.
这种游戏是如何运作的呢？科学知识被隐藏在期刊里，除非你正在做播客。然后突然之间，它就有了生命。我们在 2010 年在中央公园启动了这个项目，并将其带入了现实。它被称为“终极积木派对”。我们在公园周围设置了 28 个受科学启发的活动。孩子们和家长们都来了。有人告诉我们，如果那天有 6000 人来到中央公园参加我们所有的活动，我们就非常幸运了。结果超过 50000 人来了。他们玩得很开心。
We had the Lego exhibit, but all of the blocks were green. So if you had to make something, you had to learn rotation, spatial rotation. We had the robot exhibit that came in from Columbia University, and the kids actually got to see how robots were made. and they played around with the parts to see if their robots would work or wouldn't work. We had the biggest Simon Says that was brought to you by Comcast, and boy, was it large. But guess what? Kids are learning emotional regulation and flexibility when they play a game like Simon says.
我们有乐高展览，但所有的积木都是绿色的。所以如果你必须制作什么东西，你必须学习旋转，空间旋转。我们有从哥伦比亚大学引进的机器人展览，孩子们实际上看到了机器人是如何制造的，他们摆弄零件，看看他们的机器人是否能工作。我们有 Comcast 带来的最大的“西蒙说”游戏，天哪，它太大了。但你猜怎么着？当孩子们玩像“西蒙说”这样的游戏时，他们正在学习情绪调节和灵活性。
We've actually seen it in brain data. So after that, I was sitting around in my honors class, which I told you, we used these approaches in my college classroom. And one of my students said, I need a project. And I said, I wonder, if you went to supermarkets, it made it more fun and more engaging, active, engaging, meaningful, socially. You got it now. What would happen? So we put signs up in the grocery store. Did you know there's a lot of learning in these aisles?
我们实际上在脑部数据中看到了这一点。在那之后，我坐在我的荣誉班里，正如我告诉你的，我们在大学课堂上使用了这些方法。我的一名学生说：“我需要一个项目。”我说：“我想知道，如果你去超市，让它变得更有趣、更具吸引力、更主动、更有意义、更具社交性——你现在明白了——会发生什么？”所以我们在杂货店贴了标语。你知道这些过道里有很多学习机会吗？
I'm a cow. Okay. So the cow took them around. And when we got to the dairy section, it was really hot. And it said, I'm a cow. do milk. What else has milk? Now, when the signs were down, parents and kids just went to the dairy section. But when the signs were up, we got 33% more conversations than when the signs were down. So we published that work and we were astounded. But one of my friends from the University of
“我是一头牛。”好的。所以牛带着他们四处走动。当我们到达乳制品区时，那里真的很热。上面写着：“我是一头牛。我产奶。还有什么有奶？”现在，当标语撤下时，家长和孩子们只是去了乳制品区。但当标语贴上时，我们的对话量比标语撤下时增加了 33%。所以我们发表了那项研究，我们感到非常震惊。但我的一个朋友，来自匹兹堡大学的
Pittsburgh, Melissa LaBerta, said, oh, come on, do you think you could do STEM? He said, go ahead, try it. So she tries, science, technology, engineering, math, puts up math games in the supermarket, and boom, she gets the same result. So another friend says, well, wouldn't work in laundromats, would it? I said, I don't know, let's try it. So she goes into laundromats and gets, well, you know the answer, the same effect. Well, maybe they don't have a supermarket around. Maybe they only have corner stores. What happens there? University of Chicago, I'm sorry, Northwestern. Susan Hespos tries it and boom, she gets the same thing with co-ops and corner stores. So, hmm, that kind of work.
Melissa LaBerta 说：“哦，得了吧，你觉得你能做 STEM 吗？”她说：“去吧，试试看。”所以她尝试了科学、技术、工程、数学，在超市里贴上数学游戏，砰！她得到了同样的结果。所以另一个朋友说：“在自助洗衣店行不通吧？”我说：“我不知道，让我们试试。”所以她走进自助洗衣店，得到了——嗯，你知道答案——同样的效果。好吧，也许他们附近没有超市。也许他们只有街角商店。那里会发生什么？芝加哥大学的——抱歉，是西北大学的 Susan Hespos 尝试了它，砰！她在合作社和街角商店也得到了同样的结果。所以，嗯，那种工作。
I wonder what would happen if we went to a bus stop. That's another place where people hang. So we go to the bus stop and wouldn't you know that if we put puzzles at the bus stop, all the kids play with the puzzles and learn STEM skills. If we put a new hopscotch built off the Happy Sad Task, looks like a hopscotch game, then the kids all of a sudden learn flexibility and social emotional control and impulse control.
我想知道如果我们去公交车站会发生什么。那是人们闲逛的另一个地方。所以我们去了公交车站，你猜怎么着？如果我们把拼图放在公交车站，所有的孩子都会玩拼图并学习 STEM 技能。如果我们放一个新的跳房子游戏，基于“快乐/悲伤任务”，看起来像跳房子游戏，那么孩子们突然就学会了灵活性、社会情感控制和冲动控制。
That's amazing. And we study this. So then one of my former grads, former postdocs, Andy Bustamante, now at University of California in California, Irvine. And he decides he's going to, for 65 bucks, he's going to paint a basketball court. and he paints the basketball court so that the three-throw line, you know, where you throw a free-throw,
这太神奇了。我们研究了这个。然后我的一位前研究生、前博士后 Andy Bustamante，现在在加州大学欧文分校。他决定花 65 美元粉刷一个篮球场。他粉刷了篮球场，使得罚球线——你知道，你投罚球的地方——
that three-point line becomes the one-one, or the four-four. And then you move to the three-quarter, then you move to the half, two-four, and then you move to the quarter, and then you assemble points and everyone's keep score up to a certain score. Boom! And this meant that fifth and sixth graders, who just played this game, for one week in recess, 15 minutes a day. All of a sudden, they were passing tests of a fraction decimal conversion, and he called it fraction ball. So we keep doing this.
那条三分线变成了“1-1”或“4-4”。然后你移动到四分之三处，然后移动到一半处，即“2-4”，然后移动到四分之一处，然后你积累分数，每个人都保持分数直到某个分数。砰！这意味着刚刚玩了这个游戏的一周内，每天 15 分钟课间休息的五六年级学生，突然之间，他们通过了分数/小数转换测试，他称之为“分数球”。所以我们一直在这样做。
We're in hospital waiting rooms. We're all of a sudden parents got off their cell phones and are talking to their kids again about the murals. We're in homeless shelters. And we're now, I think, in 22 cities. And we're in countries around the world. So it's growing, growing, growing. And I hope everyone would like to bring these science-infused games to your city. We're working with communities, and the communities help us build them.
我们在医院候诊室。突然间，家长们放下了手机，开始再次与孩子们谈论壁画。我们在无家可归者收容所。我想我们现在已经在 22 个城市了。我们遍布世界各地的国家。所以它在不断增长、增长、增长。我希望每个人都愿意把这些融入科学的游戏带到你们的城市。我们正在与社区合作，社区帮助我们建造它们。
That sounds like a lot of fun and an opportunity for people to interact where they wouldn't normally, you know how we all might go to a bus stop and never talk to the other people. This gives you a reason to be talking to them, which is great. It's exactly. It's what I call the New Public Square. Now, we're taping this episode right at the start of the holiday shopping season. So I want to know if you have any advice for parents on what kinds of toys they might get their kids for the holidays, toys that are fun, but they also encourage learning and growth. Yeah, well, you know, it's really fun.
这听起来很有趣，也为人们提供了一个在平时不会互动的情况下进行互动的机会。你知道我们所有人可能会去公交车站却从不与其他人交谈。这给了你一个与他们交谈的理由，这太棒了。正是如此。这就是我所说的“新公共广场”。现在，我们是在假日购物季开始时录制这一集的。所以我想知道您是否对家长们有什么建议，关于他们可以给孩子买什么样的玩具，既有趣又能鼓励学习和成长。是的，你知道，这真的很有趣。
Just the other day, somebody called me to write a story about smart toys. So it's, you know, it's end of 2023 and AI is with us. And we've learned how to put the chips and the toys. and even before AI, my group and other groups had studied, what's happening with these digital toys? And we got some very clear answers. With the digital toys, it turns out that the parents are cut out of the interaction. The digital toys talk a lot.
就在前几天，有人打电话让我写一个关于智能玩具的故事。所以，你知道，现在是 2023 年底，人工智能就在我们身边。我们已经学会了如何把芯片放进玩具里。甚至在人工智能出现之前，我的团队和其他团队就已经研究过：这些数字玩具发生了什么？我们得到了一些非常明确的答案。对于数字玩具，结果发现家长被排除在互动之外了。数字玩具说得太多了。
And they seem to get the kid engaged, but the kid gets word of them pretty quickly because they're kind of cool for a bit, but they only have routine things that they can say. So as it turns out, I thought, well, I wonder if it's all digital toys this year that are being recommended as holiday toys. What's on the list?
它们似乎让孩子参与进来了，但孩子很快就对它们感到厌倦，因为它们虽然暂时看起来很酷，但它们只能说一些常规的东西。所以事实证明，我想，嗯，我不知道今年是否所有被推荐为假日玩具的都是数字玩具。清单上有什么？
And I was shocked to find that, well, there were a few smart toys in the 10 top sellers this year, most of them were your traditional toys. So let's look at it more closely. The blocks and construction toys are still right up there, along with the train sets. Why? Because to build a train pattern that your train can go on, you need spatial skills. And spatial skills, they actually predict pretty strongly what your later math skills are going to be like.
我很震惊地发现，虽然今年前 10 名畅销产品中有几个智能玩具，但大多数还是传统玩具。让我们仔细看看。积木和建筑玩具仍然名列前茅，还有火车套装。为什么？因为要搭建火车轨道，你需要空间技能。而空间技能实际上非常强烈地预测了你以后的数学技能会是什么样。
Hmm. Then you have to know the physics and the spatial skills in order to build. the top tower that won't just topple on you. So construction's good. Well, how about the art toys? Oh, they're still hot. So that's good. The make-believe is still happening,
嗯。然后你必须知道物理学和空间技能才能搭建。那座不会倒塌的高塔。所以建筑类玩具很好。那艺术类玩具呢？哦，它们仍然很受欢迎。所以那很好。假装游戏仍然在发生，
especially after the Barbie movie, three of the top ten sellers or the Barbie dollhouse and others, where kids engaged in make-believe are learning how to tell narrative stories. And when they learn how to tell narrative stories and make it up themselves, they become better writers, better thinkers, and yes, they learn how to read better. So actually, the standard fair that's been around for a pretty long time are pretty good educational toys.
特别是在《芭比》电影之后，前十名畅销产品中有三个是芭比娃娃屋和其他玩具，孩子们在假装游戏中学习如何讲述叙事故事。当他们学会如何讲述叙事故事并自己编造时，他们会成为更好的作家、更好的思想家，是的，他们学会了更好地阅读。所以实际上，存在了很长时间的标准玩具是非常好的教育玩具。
I guess people didn't know the term educational toys as an advertisement seller at that time, but to be honest, they're still pretty good from a psychological point of view. As long as they're fun, you know, I think you don't want kids to understand that what you're really doing is you're sneaking in some learning. Oh, well, you know, it's all learning at the end of the game, really. Our brain is working all the time. It just turns out that any time we get the chance to really be active learners, to be seeking information, to be curious and creative, that's when we learn the most. and I think as long as we appreciate that in ourselves and in our children, we're going to be better off because not everything is like IKEA furniture
我想人们当时并不知道“教育玩具”这个词作为广告卖点，但老实说，从心理学角度来看，它们仍然相当不错。只要它们有趣，你知道，我认为你不想让孩子们明白你真正做的是偷偷塞进一些学习内容。哦，好吧，你知道，游戏结束时一切都是学习，真的。我们的大脑一直在工作。事实证明，任何时候我们有机会真正成为主动的学习者，去寻求信息，去好奇和创造，那才是我们学得最多的时候。我认为只要我们在自己和孩子身上认识到这一点，我们就会变得更好，因为并不是所有东西都像宜家家具那样，
where they tell you exactly where to put it. You know? Although it still doesn't come together. I was going to say to me it still doesn't come naturally, but my point is it doesn't, you know, these things, even in the Lego sets, they give you three things you can make from every one. It's not as much fun otherwise because you just make the one set and then you did it and it's done. Let's talk again about some of these electronic things that are out there, computer-based learning games.
他们告诉你确切地放在哪里。你知道吗？尽管它仍然组装不起来。我本来想说对我来说它仍然不自然，但我的意思是它不是，你知道，这些东西，即使在乐高套装中，他们也给你每套可以制作的三种东西。否则就没那么有趣了，因为你只是制作了一套，然后你就完成了。让我们再谈谈外面的一些电子产品，基于计算机的学习游戏。
Many elementary schools are using games that are supposed to teach children math or reading as part of the curriculum. Does that count as playful learning or are they just like using a different tool? It's just not chalk on a blackboard. Most of it is just another tool, though there is some really good stuff out there. And if you can find it, there are places like common sense media and all that direct you to a lot of good places. But I would say, be careful. The real key is for kids to have choice and voice. And that kind of agency represents the active domain.
许多小学正在使用应该教孩子数学或阅读的游戏作为课程的一部分。这算作游戏化学习吗？还是它们只是像使用不同的工具？这只是不是黑板上的粉笔而已。大多数只是另一种工具，尽管外面确实有一些非常好的东西。如果你能找到它们，有一些地方像“常识媒体”等会引导你到很多好的地方。但我会说，要小心。真正的关键是让孩子有选择权和发言权。那种自主权代表了主动领域。
A chance to be social, to have other people to do it with makes a big difference. And we've seen that even in educational apps when kids are working solo versus working together, they actually can learn more. So there is good stuff out there. Schools have found some of it. I don't know that everything has to be a game. You know, some things you just have to learn like the multiplication tables, and that's okay. On the other hand, I do want to be conscious that these more gamified platforms can sometimes be really fun for kids and kids do retain it.
有机会进行社交，有其他人一起做，这会有很大的不同。我们已经看到，即使在教育类应用程序中，当孩子们独自工作与一起工作时，他们实际上可以学到更多。所以外面有好东西。学校已经找到了一些。我不知道是否一切都必须是游戏。你知道，有些东西你只需要学习，比如乘法表，那没关系。另一方面，我确实想意识到这些游戏化平台有时对孩子来说真的很有趣，而且孩子们确实记住了。
I know there are companies, again, everything that these companies have isn't great, whether it's Meadow or it's Roblox or whatever, that are building a lot of new platforms where the kids get to build the cities and the kids get to build the designs. That gives them choice. And I think those are even more powerful examples of how kids can learn. Because truthfully, you can't build a city if the math doesn't work. You know, you can't put a building on another building. So, you know, those are good ways to learn to. And let's talk about what you're working on now. I mentioned in the intro that you just got a $19 million grant.
我知道有一些公司，同样，这些公司所拥有的一切并不都是伟大的，无论是 Meta 还是 Roblox 等，它们正在构建许多新的平台，孩子们可以在那里建造城市，孩子们可以进行设计。这给了他们选择权。我认为这些是孩子们如何学习的更有力的例子。因为说实话，如果数学不成立，你就无法建造城市。你知道，你不能把一栋建筑放在另一栋建筑上。所以，你知道，这些也是很好的学习方式。让我们谈谈你现在正在做什么。我在介绍中提到你刚刚获得了 1900 万美元的资助。
Yeah. What are you doing with that money? What are you hoping to learn? Yeah. I mean, it was even better. It was pretty close to $20 million. It was insane. But we're so proud of it and so excited.
是的。你打算用这笔钱做什么？你希望学到什么？是的。我的意思是，它甚至更好。它非常接近 2000 万美元。这太疯狂了。但我们为此感到非常自豪和兴奋。
And what we're doing is we're working with funding from the Lego Foundation. We are working in four states. And I wish I could say it's just me, but I don't really wish it could say it's just me. Science is a team sport. And I've been, you know, so fortunate over the years to work with the top scientists in the country who have been writing about how to use the best learning techniques for children in schools for a long time. So we're going to be doing a longitudinal study from kindergarten through fourth grade. And we are going to be in Illinois, Texas, California, and Virginia in public school systems.
我们正在做的是，我们正在利用乐高基金会的资助进行工作。我们正在四个州开展工作。我希望我能说这只是我，但我并不真的希望说这只是我。科学是一项团队运动。多年来，我有幸与全国顶尖的科学家合作，他们长期以来一直在撰写关于如何在学校为儿童使用最佳学习技术的文章。所以我们将从幼儿园到四年级进行一项纵向研究。我们将进入伊利诺伊州、德克萨斯州、加利福尼亚州和弗吉尼亚州的公立学校系统。
We've targeted some under-resourced schools. Certainly schools have very diverse populations. And with the team, we've designed how to actually operationalize the active and engaged, meaningful, socially interactive pillars that we use to define guided play and playful learning so that it can be used in a classroom environment. So for one, we think we have to have less whole group instruction and a little bit more of students working. in pairs. So moving not to totally no direct instruction, but less direct instruction in the schools. And when students can see how that works and they're talking to others as they're learning and they have choices and when it's more meaningful and it's more culturally relevant, or let me say, you know, expresses some of the community values is maybe a better way to put it, then I think
我们针对了一些资源不足的学校。当然，学校的学生群体非常多元。我们与团队一起设计了如何将我们用来定义引导式游戏和游戏化学习的“积极参与、有意义、社会互动”这三大支柱真正付诸实践，以便将其应用于课堂环境。首先，我们认为应该减少全班统一授课，增加学生结对学习的时间。也就是说，并不是完全取消直接教学，而是减少学校里的直接教学。当学生看到这种方式如何运作，在学习时能与他人交流，拥有选择权，并且学习内容更有意义、更具文化相关性——或者换句话说，更能体现社区价值观时，我认为
they're going to learn better. We're using a coaching system in the schools where we will be working with coaches in each state who will be training coaches and teachers in the particular states. And then as we do that, we hope to leave these methods with the teachers and with the schools so that it can scale up and can be self-sustaining. And the other exciting part of it is, you know, years, I think since no child left behind and even before, we've known that the education system that we have in the United States, and I may say even globally earlier today I got off the phone with UNESCO, and I've also been working with the OECD in Europe, is that our education was fashioned for a prior era. It was fashioned for a time.
他们会学得更好。我们正在学校使用一种辅导系统，与各州的教练合作，由他们负责培训当地的教练和教师。通过这种方式，我们希望将这些方法留给教师和学校，从而实现规模化并保持自我持续发展。另一个令人兴奋的部分是，我认为自从《不让一个孩子掉队》法案出台以来，甚至在此之前，我们就已经意识到，我们现有的美国教育体系，甚至可以说全球的教育体系——今天早些时候我刚和联合国教科文组织通过电话，也一直在与欧洲的经合组织合作——都是为过去那个时代设计的。它是为那个时代量身打造的。
when we had assembly lines and where we were talking about a manufacturing perspective. And that's where we get, whether it's our grade systems or whether it's our assessment systems or whether it's students sitting in rows listening passively to, you know, the brilliant person in the front of the room who is dispensing knowledge. And we need to change that model. We now live in an era of computers where kids have access to more information at their fingertips than they've ever had before. And knowledge is doubling and tripling at such a rate, even before AI. It was down to 12 months. All the information that we ever had in the world was doubling every 12 months.
那时我们有流水线，谈论的是制造业视角。这就是我们评分系统、评估系统，以及学生成排坐着被动听讲的由来，听着前面那位博学的人传授知识。我们需要改变这种模式。我们现在生活在计算机时代，孩子们触手可及的信息比以往任何时候都多。知识的增长速度正在成倍增加，甚至在人工智能出现之前，知识翻倍周期就已经缩短到了12个月。世界上所有的信息每12个月就会翻一番。
Now there's AI. I mean, forget about it. It's probably every 10 seconds. So in that kind of a world, using an old-fashioned school system with an old-fashioned curriculum isn't going to get our kids to thrive. And the business world has moved on. But as Time magazine has said, if Rip Van Winkle came back today, the only thing that would look familiar is likely the school system. It's made teachers unhappy because they know it's not the way to teach. And we need to trust our teachers again.
现在有了人工智能，别提了，可能每10秒钟就会翻一番。因此，在这样的世界里，使用老式的学校系统和老式的课程体系无法让我们的孩子茁壮成长。商业世界已经向前发展了。正如《时代》杂志所说，如果“李伯大梦”今天醒来，唯一让他感到熟悉的东西可能就是学校系统。这让教师们感到不快乐，因为他们知道这不是正确的教学方式。我们需要再次信任我们的教师。
We need to create a system where they are happy teaching and don't want to run out the door. We need a system where our kids are prepared for that workplace of tomorrow, to be good collaborators and communicators, to know their content but critically think, to be kids who have creative innovation, to have kids who also know how to take the risk and the confidence and the grit to move on and do things well. When we have a school system that creates those outcomes, which every parent wants for their child, then we're going to be able to mirror what the parents are saying, have a school system that's more modernized and future directed. and where teachers want to teach again. And that's what we hope to bring in this study. Well, that's a tall order, but it's important,
我们需要创造一个让他们乐于教学、不想逃离的系统。我们需要一个让孩子们为未来职场做好准备的系统，让他们成为优秀的合作者和沟通者，既掌握知识又能批判性思考，成为具有创造力和创新精神的孩子，同时也要让孩子们懂得如何承担风险，拥有自信和毅力去不断前进并把事情做好。当我们拥有一个能产生这些成果的学校系统时——这也是每位家长对孩子的期望——我们就能够呼应家长的诉求，拥有一个更现代化、面向未来的学校系统，让教师们重新渴望教学。这就是我们希望通过这项研究带来的成果。嗯，这任务艰巨，但很重要，
and I hope that you achieve your goals. I'm going to thank you so much for joining me today. This has been really interesting. It's always great playing with you. Well, thank you. We can play again whenever. Just let me know, but we've got to get that adult recess. You know, it's got to be put on the table.
我希望你们能实现目标。非常感谢您今天加入我的节目。这真的非常有趣。和你一起“玩”总是很棒。好的，谢谢。我们随时可以再一起玩。随时告诉我，但我们一定要安排那场“成人课间休息”。你知道的，这必须提上日程。
All right. I'm all for it. All right. Cheers. Thanks again. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman.
好的，我完全支持。好的，干杯。再次感谢。您可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 或在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何您获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》往期节目。如果您对未来的播客有任何评论或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由 Lee Wynerman 制作。
Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的音效剪辑师是 Chris Condyenne。感谢收听美国心理学会的节目。我是 Kim Mills。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。